Hey guys how's it going it's Justine. Today I am so excited because I'm unboxing for you the new Nintendo 2DS
XL now this is announced a while ago and a lot of you guys were like Justine are you going to get it tell us we need to know
and if you're new to my channel you probably don't know that I was beyond obsessed with my 3DS
I took that thing everywhere. I can forget my wallet at home
But I would not forget my 3DS. Street passes were my life. Now since the Nintendo Switch came out
And it doesn't have street pass
I'm not as inclined to take it everywhere and theres 2 new games that are coming out
Miitopia and Hey Pikmin. Don't get me wrong
I do wish it was on the switch so that I could carry around one device and one device to rule them all
but clearly by the launch of this new handheld device
It's very obvious that Nintendo is still in the market for these. So what I'm curious as to
What is that distinction between who would buy a Switch and who would buy a 2DS. I'd be interested to see which you guys think
about that in the comments below
But in the meantime let's open this up and let's take a look. I'm also so excited about the Pikmin amiibo
I may or may not do a little bit of gameplay for you
but I don't know how to capture from a 3DS, 2DS.
I never even played in 3D does anybody actually ever really play in 3d on their 3DS? Stop talking open up
I'm shook.
They have a charger with it. That was like the biggest dilemma in the past 3DS. you have to buy the charger separate
Can you even? I can't.
I like the blue a lot too this looks so good
Here it is
Got our charging port back here. Our stylus.
Headphone jack. Why is there a big slot, I always did the digital downloads. And I'm so used to seeing the tiny tiny little
Cards for the Nintendo Switch. So let's do a size comparison between 3DS. This is probably my favorite version other than the galaxy 3DSXL
This is a gamestop NES exclusive my mom bought me this for Christmas I believe. I was so excited about it
It's really not that much smaller to be honest with you the 3DSXL is a little bit taller
You shoulda been a baller shot caller
When you open it up, it has a much smoother feel. This has like the click
So as for like a screen size comparison, the screen looks almost the same size.
So basically the 2DSf fits quite nicely
into the 3DS
Let's take a little peek in comparison to the Nintendo Switch. Look at you, you look good
Got our Nintendo Switch, got our 2DS, which basically fits
Quite nicely there in the middle of the screen
What is so intriguing to me
Is I really forgot how big these cards were I mean in comparison to the Switch cartridges
You know something I never did I never did taste the cartridge
I don't want to do it. I don't want to do it. I'm scared should I
Like what's the bad side?
Oh God. Oh my God
How did I not do that until now how have I?
Not tasted the Nintendo Swish cartridge for the five months that this thing been *gags*
Oh my God. It tastes like a freaking.. it tastes so disgusting. I really should have just trusted the internet
Thanksfully i didn't get a good lick of it, and I've been drinking this. Oh my God the taste is still in my freakin tongue
I'm such an idiot. I'm so stupid. I told myself
I was not going to taste the frickin cartridge never say never who said that Justin Bieber
Let's take a peek at these little amiibo. Oh, smells so, like, just
Beautiful plastic. There's so much detail
in this thing, like look at the grass
So that's that. The Nintendo Switch cartridge does in fact taste disgusting
The 2DSXL is much smaller than the 3DSXL but not by that much
I'll see you guys later. Thanks for watching, bye.